estamos de regreso para actualizar la
información económica en france 24 y
para eso nos acompaña por supuesto
nuestro compañero luis méndez zúrich
louis muy buenas noches vamos a comenzar
en europa para hablar sobre una
situación que preocupa a muchos países y
que tienen que ver con la energía en el
continente que está pasando está pasando
que se están quedando sin reservas para
producir energía y sobre ello el
presidente ruso vladimir putin
responsabilizó a las políticas
energéticas de la unión europea e indicó
que podría suministrar magias tan pronto
el gasoducto nord stream 2 reciba la
aprobación del gobierno alemán
europa depende en un 80% de las
importaciones de gas y está atravesando
problemas con los suministros para la
generación de energía esto ha provocado
un alza en los precios de la
electricidad en las últimas semanas y
los mismos se han mantenido altos ante
la expectativa de un invierno frío en el
continente pero escuchemos que dijo el
presidente de rusia principal proveedor
de gas a europa sobre la situación
no más toca
los mercados europeos del gas podrían en
este momento enfrentar una escasez de 70
mil millones de metros cúbicos de gas
eso es mucho muy similar
siervo de tropas llegaron europa toca
tura el primer gasoducto de nord stream
2 está lleno de gas si el regulador
alemán otorga su autorización mañana el
suministro de 17 mil 500 millones de
metros cúbicos de gas comenzará pasado
mañana es kirchner mientras tanto la
unión europea en conjunto busca
alternativas para disminuir el impacto
de esta situación en la población
escuchemos hubiésemos presentado como
comisión un conjunto de medidas
relativas a los precios de la energía y
a los precios de la electricidad para
ayudar a los consumidores
sumersión
más sobre la estrategia tiene que ser
invertir masivamente en energías limpias
y renovables una energía confiable que
se produce en europa y es el futuro en
europe antiestrés
bueno les seguiremos tus crónicas para
ver cómo avanza esta crítica de la
situación seguimos en europa pero además
medios españoles sabrán sobre un acuerdo
entre países europeos y eeuu por la
denominada tasa google de que estamos
hablando no estamos hablando de esa
tesis puesto que países europeos
colocaron a las empresas digitales pero
en relación a tu comentario en
específico fue la publicación el país de
españa que manifestó la situación y ésta
se refiere al impuesto de los países
europeos que le están cobrando a las
empresas digitales de acuerdo con el
diario los países se mantendrán el cobro
de esta tasa hasta el año 2023 mientras
dure la negociación en el seno de la
opte por un impuesto global a las
multinacionales al tiempo y eeuu mostró
su compromiso de retirar los aranceles
que habían puesto productos de francia
italia austria españa y reino unido- en
represalia por esta imposición los
países vienen cobrando una tasa de 3 por
ciento a las empresas digitales bueno
les pasamos ahora américa latina el fmi
presentó su informe de perspectivas
regionales y a diferencia del que fue
dado a conocer durante las reuniones
anuales del organismo y el banco mundial
éste se mostró menos optimista de
acuerdo a lo informado por nigel charts
director interino del departamento para
el hemisferio occidental la recuperación
de américa latina y el caribe a niveles
previos de la pandemia podría tomar más
de 5 años a pesar de ello el informe
regional reveló un crecimiento de 63 %
para la región en este año uno de louis
y hablando de perspectivas regionales
vamos a ver así donde los mercados se
están desplomando y esto por diferencias
en torno a un programa social y la razón
fue que los inversionistas mostraron
temor de que el gobierno supere el techo
de deuda para llevar a cabo la
implementación del programa auxilio
brasil tal como lo preside plantea
bolsonaro de acuerdo con el diario folha
de sao paulo el ejecutivo y quienes
respaldan el congreso habrían
introducido una medida que daría
espacios para superar el techo de gasto
en un año electoral
bolsonaro ha propuesto el plan auxilio
brasil un programa social que sustituirá
al plan bolsa familia y este sería por
un valor de 400 reales es decir unos 70
dólares aproximadamente de brasil a
china hacemos un viaje de largo hablar
de una noticia que tiene que ver con que
este país recibió de buena manera el
proceso de exclusión arancelaria que le
propone eeuu la jefa sepas bueno una
semana cuando el representante de la
oficina comercial estadounidense anunció
que su país comenzaría con un proceso de
establecer posibles exclusiones
arancelarias de productos chinos para la
portavoz del ministerio de comercio
en la abolición de aranceles favorecería
no sólo ambos países sino a la
recuperación económica global vale
recordar que bajo la presidencia de
trump se impusieron algunos aranceles
como medidas proteccionista y también
para disminuir el déficit comerciales de
ambos países gracias por este repaso por
las principales noticias económicas de
américa latina del resto del mundo a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]